in elbow drops oh and you hit elbow
collapses is unified with your body and
you kid
okay that those are like kinda static
version when you're kind of missing
something all right
what Wendy let's say you walk towards me
there's a little bit when he walked
those where he can't affect his balance
if you hit him mid stride mid attention
mid mid thought you understand that okay
so versus he walks towards me I stopped
him and then I push him okay when I
wanna stood right where he is in that
made intention okay
Oh
yes
uou turn just yet for my wings and then
when I turn my weight my weight my
weight goes to the front foot okay so
that's where my hands going to end up
under my weight then when I wanted to
move out of by the way okay so
don't use your arm please go out here
turn your hips okay then you want it to
move you turn your hips back
was smooth
so the point we're trying to do here is
that that's my angle deviation okay so
I'm not here and so what it's moving her
if she's coming in I've moved off the
line so you guys see how did you know
that switch of my face I'm not like this
I'm gonna be nervous see that okay
she's punching me what stop I'm right
there if you want anything I want to do
I'm in range
okay so I don't want to get these lines
like that you have to learn to rotate
around your spine okay
she's not even on me everything has to
be the same
this elbow if I bring it in is in
alignment right there you guys see that
but I want to hit these distressed enjoy
breathing remember that from ground
fighting remember that okay so I only
have that and I move it oh that's all I
think forward
right right Gary right so if I can eat
all right he doesn't want his heart
busted right ha so he stays ahead of the
energy right right everyone got that
concept okay so he comes in he doesn't
wait for me to do that buzu move in hit
him
got it okay so this is no different when
I'm coming in he goes I don't go all
guys stop me you got a long time to go
still a lot of shots can happen in that
time left so you know that you tell me
you guys are always do it again this is
where it comes in but now you gotta do
it on the body so when he comes in you
see I I think it squeezed out at second
okay I don't come in boom
and he'll do everything for you you will
just be free squeeze that like that
you